(bouncy, electronic bass music)
- What's up everybody?
This is Gary Vaynerchuk,
and welcome to Episode Two
of #AskGaryVee.
- [Voiceover] Jan asks, "How
do I create interesting content
"for a boring subject
such as a hardware store?
"Any ideas?
"Thanks."
- Jan, a hardware store
is very far from boring.
I mean we've talked to
people that are asking about
highways and cement,
and all sorts of things,
and I have no idea how you think
that a hardware store is boring
when you're selling tools,
something that tons, and I mean tons
of people are actually passionate about.
So, you know, the fact
that you've categorized it
as boring makes me say,
"We have to work on your mindset,"
because you need to open it up.
Because construction and homes,
and DYI, do it yourself, all these things
are happening right now,
and I would argue that a bunch of people
who are watching right now
are gonna leave comments
in YouTube saying, "That
is far from boring."
So, I would say, "It's not boring.
"The content is quite easy,
"and get your ass to it."
- [Voiceover] Eric asks,
"Need your advice on getting
"the first 10 customers for
a creative service startup.
"We make product videos
for online retailers."
- Eric, I once made a video,
and let's link this up down here below,
and let's put it up right here.
Can you guys make another
video move in here
or is it just gonna be a still shot?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, if it's on YouTube,
we can do--
- We can make it move, beautiful.
There's a famous video I made,
where I cold-call people
for customers, right?
And it was something people really loved.
And that's my answer.
To get the first 10 customers,
you have to grind.
Sorry DRock, I know I screwed up here.
But you have to grind.
What I mean by grinding
is you have to just
reach out to every single person.
Like you just have to roll up on people,
and be like, "Hey, will you buy my stuff?"
- Yeah.
- There it was.
One customer.
So...
(laughing)
That was awesome.
Did you catch her in the background or no?
I mean, you just have to ask.
So, go to every single person in the world
that will possibly buy your thing,
and ask them to buy your thing.
- [Voiceover] Will asks,
"I'm taught in marketing
"that people are basically sheep.
"What does that say about your idea
"that the 'consumer decides'?"
- Will, I don't know
who's teaching you this,
some university or some
douchebag marketers,
but you know, there's truth
in that we can influence.
I mean marketing clearly influences,
but the customer's own
preconceived notions
and DNA, and the way they grew up,
and all the other variables,
are a factor as well.
And they get to choose.
At the end of the day,
we're not hypnotizing people.
There's not some weird thing floating
above my head that saying,
"Buy my book."
You know you need to get them
to post that under there, right?
You know, that's not happening,
and so, you know, I think that is a very,
all-in, 100% way to look at it.
Do I think marketing influences people?
Of course.
Do I think we're hypnotizing people?
No.
- [Voiceover] You called
him out for a bad question.
- Yes, he's back?
- [Voiceover] Yeah he's back.
- [Voiceover] Dragga asks,
"I'm an indie music producer.
"What tips do you have to promo my content
"using social media marketing?"
- Dragga, what's up?
You're back.
And I respect that.
You're in Episode One and Two.
You one day will be a trivia question.
So, the question is,
look you're an indie guy,
you're trying to promote.
I'm actually gonna move the mic to Steve.
He's not even expecting this.
Go there. Go there.
Do you get the sound?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, we can.
- You're good with sound?
The camera's got its own sound?
- [Voiceover] Yep.
- Go ahead.
Say what you just said to me.
- So, Dragga, I looked
at your Twitter account,
and you posted a remix of a Rihanna track
eight times in the last 24 hours,
since we aired the last
episode of this show actually.
- That's a little bit
overwhelming, Dragga.
Now, couple things.
I think the thing to really
think about is listening.
I was actually clicking, and
that's why we got focused.
I don't know what he was doing there,
but he was replying to somebody.
I like the replying in Twitter.
That's a tactic.
Look, here's what I think it's all about.
The quality of the music matters.
Building up your SoundCloud matters.
How does one do that?
One of the ways to really do that
is to become old school in some ways.
Believe it or not, I'm
gonna go left field on you.
How 'bout some music message boards?
But not spamming them.
Becoming a part of that community.
How about searching every single person
that Tweeted about Rihanna.
Steve pull it up.
Every single person who
Tweeted about Rihanna.
Let me guess,
but I'm gonna think
it's a shitload, right?
And so, in that shitload,
jumping in and engaging with those people.
Now you gotta spend a lot of time.
You decided to do a Rihanna remix, not me.
So that means you've gotta go through it,
and it's gonna take you a couple hours,
because everybody's
gonna be Tweeting like,
"Rihanna's hot.
"Fuck Rihanna."
All that stuff. And you're
gonna have to find the people
that are actually talking
about Rihanna's music,
which I don't know,
probably small percentage of
what's going on on Twitter.
You've gotta jump into that
and engage with it authentically.
Engaging, and you've heard
of the 19 year-old dude move
is not saying, "Check out my track."
You've gotta just kind of,
you know, jam with people.
I would recommend, if
you're jamming people,
and jamming with people, not jamming.
If you're jamming with people,
during that period,
changing the URL in your Twitter profile
to be a direct link to the Rihanna track.
That's right folks.
That was a tactic, and
that's why #AskGaryVee's
gonna be a big-time show.
If you're deciding to
do something specific
for a two-day period, like Dragga should,
around engaging people
about Rihanna's music
that actually talk about the music.
I'd recommend he changes
his Twitter profile's URL
from his probably homepage,
or whatever he's got going on,
to the actual link to the
SoundCloud of that show,
because while he's engaging,
people are gonna be like,
"Who the hell's Dragga?
"Let me click this link in his URL."
Boom, they're listening to that.
The viral loop gets going.
- [Voiceover] Justin asks,
"Where are the best places
"for hiring great employees these days?
"What's your process?"
- The best places to hire great employees
is actually, this is kind of
like the honey and bees thing.
My process is a little bit different.
I'm actively running a
social and digital agency,
and I am at the lucky stage of my career
where I'm a known personality in that,
and I'm public speaking.
I'm doing the #AskGaryVee Show.
Plug.
And, you know,
it's coming to us, right?
I'm at that place now.
So that's not practical
for the far majority
of people watching this,
and because I want this to be practical,
I would say what I would
think is very simply
the best tactic for all of you watching,
who want to hire good people
is to search the key
terms on Twitter search
that are talking about the
things that you do for a living,
and then doing the homework.
The dirty little secret is my friends,
is most people don't want to work.
You know how easy it is
to find good employees?
Let me explain.
You go to Twitter search.
You search the terms
around the job description
that you want, not the
job description terms,
but the kind of things they'd be doing.
Looking at people talking
about design websites,
design forums, design aspects,
and then looking around
what people are saying.
Then clicking on their profile.
Clicking their homepage.
Probably landing on
their design portfolio.
Finding four people that
you think do a good job.
Emailing them or Tweeting at them saying,
"Do you want to interview for a job?
"Are you looking for a job?"
Three of the four say, "No."
One says, "Yes."
The other three give you four referrals
that are kind of like them.
You've got five people to interview
and you hire one of those people.
But that just took eight hours, didn't it?
And that my friends,
is how you actually do it.
Because everybody's
looking for quick tactics
to make it easy, and putting in the work
always, always matters.
You, with a little bit of me,
we're changing the Q and A world.
(clicking tongue)
(bouncy, electronic bass music)